i've been hearing like noise like
footsteps above my room
it's definitely it's definitely the
attic not like the next
upstairs neighbors it's really freaky
you know all those annoying zoom
meetings you've had to do during
i'll do my quarantine after class all
right benji
i'm not doing this the ratchet oh i'm
done with this stupid-ass claw
okay well shutter has just come out with
an absolutely bonkers idea
why don't we hold the seance online now
i know what you're
thinking think story you dumb dumb
seances can't be done online
ghosts are old and if they're anything
like my parents they wouldn't even know
how to log in
but that's where you're wrong in this
video we're gonna cover shutter's host a
movie filmed entirely during quarantine
how on earth was this movie made and
who or what is the demon found within so
light a candle put on your quarantine
mask and make sure to like and subscribe
because here
we go the story of how host came to be
started with a viral video
in late april of 2020. director rob
savage was alone in his apartment
quarantined and thought wouldn't it
really suck if there was a murderer
living in my attic
so he did what any good writer director
would do and made a short film about it
but not just that he decided to do it
while pranking his friends
so rob went and recorded himself going
into his attic and
spoiler alert for those who haven't seen
the two minute short
i'll leave a link to it in the
description
yes his friends didn't know that this
was a recording so he got his
friends genuine reactions from this
prank he didn't reveal that it was a
prank until 30 seconds after it was over
allowing him to capture their reactions
changing from laughter to concern
to silence here's a photo of the device
rob made himself
where he put his phone in front of his
laptop so he could stream the recording
to his friends
the video went viral racking in millions
of views across
various news sites leading rob to pitch
a longer version to shutter
an online streaming platform that
specializes in horror thrillers and
suspense
they loved the idea and he was off to
the races in fact there was a bidding
war for the movie since
nothing else could be made during the
lockdown there was just one problem
how do you film a movie at the height of
a pandemic
luckily the premise itself six friends
meeting over zoom to conduct a seance is
social distancing at its finest director
rob had the actors record their scenes
in dialogue and
with the help of experts in makeup and
stunts directed the actors on how to do
their own visual effects such as
moving the chair the actors lit the
scenes themselves
did their own makeup and operated their
own cameras while
rob directed them all from his own
apartment the story itself was based off
a 10-page treatment and they essentially
built it off the locations and crew they
had access to
for example rob had a special effects
makeup artist who hand crafted pieces of
latex
mailed them to the actress then got
online to instruct her on how to apply
the pieces to her face
his glitches like dan says yeah
one of the actresses was rooming with a
stunt coordinator so they were able to
utilize him to legally perform some of
the more dangerous stunts
the story even takes place during the
pandemic
we see one of the characters wearing a
mask the characters joke about social
distancing
and near the end two of the characters
elbow bump instead of shaking hands
all in all the film was shot in two
weeks and from initial idea to
distribution
it was an astonishingly short 12 weeks
now you might recognize
some of the actors in the film are
robb's actual friends who were in his
viral prank video
haley gemma carolyn emma and rodina
all star in the feature version now i
struggled to define it as a feature as
it's only
56 minutes long rob was contractually
obligated to deliver
an at least 30 minute long film and he
tinkered with the idea to make it a
real-time
40-minute call which is the time limit
for basic zoom meetings involving three
or more participants
now the film does manipulate time in
this respect stretching this 40 minutes
to 56 as seen at the ending
when the countdown to the remaining
meeting time is shown in the top left
corner but let's rewind to the beginning
host refers to haley the host of the
zoom meeting who takes off a piece of
tape on our webcam
as if the fbi or some stranger is
watching her little does she know that
someone will be watching her just not
someone from this world the group of six
friends are holding an online seance and
have been requested by their medium
salen to bring
items associated with the dead person
they'd like to connect with
for example teddy brings a creepy
ballerina music box that once belonged
to his grandmother
salen calls these trigger objects as
they may help in establishing a
connection with those who have passed
these spirits live in a place called the
astral plane which seems to be a place
existing between
our world and the next the film does a
great job at
pacing both the tension and scares for
example early on in the seance a creepy
knocking is heard only for us to
discover it's the medium's delivery guy
gemma then tells the group she feels
something in her room and
someone whispered the name jack to her
she tells everyone that jack was a nice
kid from school who once helped her when
she was a kid and he later hung himself
all of the girls are freaked out by
gemma's story but she soon reveals it
was
all a joke just like how rob played a
joke on his friends in his original
video this is the event that releases a
demonic spirit haley's chair is pushed
back
carolyn finds a pair of skinny legs in
her attic which disappear
emma's wine glass breaks on its own and
haley takes a polaroid to find what
appears to be an image of someone
hanging themselves
it's only when the group informed salem
that gemma's story about jack was made
up that we get a clearer picture of
what's going on
gemma has disrespected the spirits and
by inviting a person who doesn't exist
has someday quote false spirit according
to salem by
making something up you've essentially
created a mask so that anything
can come through and wear that mask it
could be something
even something demonic now there is a
scene later in the movie where the
spirit actually
levitates a mask which is likely a
callback to this
so essentially by gemma making up this
story of a boy named jack who hung
himself
she's invited a demonic spirit to
manifest and take control of that
made-up boy
that's why there are several references
to a noose in the film like
when teddy finds one in the barn or the
one found in haley's polaroid what
essentially follows is a series of
increasingly
paranormal events like the lights
turning on and off rodina's missing
boyfriend who collapses to the ground
seemingly out of nowhere and my personal
favorite teddy's girlfriend
levitating over the pool this one i
couldn't 100 confirm how they did but
considering the actor who plays teddy is
a professional stuntman and rigger
my guess is they actually set up a
device to lift her over the pool
now i gotta hand it to gemma who is one
of the final two survivors who ends up
running to her friend haley's house but
still manages to put on her mask
there she finds haley is still alive and
with a few remaining seconds left in
their zoom call
and yes they're still filming for some
reason they uncover the demon before
their session
ends this is the demon jack but on imdb
he's simply listed as the spirit the
film ends with the termination of their
zoom call and just a really cool
short and sweet end credit sequence the
credits are done as if all new members
were in the zoom call
plus you can make out the date july 30th
2020 which is the actual day the movie
was released on shutter i went into this
movie thinking i would hate it another
found footage gimmick but it delivers
some pretty good scares if these are the
types of movies you're into
director rob savage has said he'd be
open to a sequel and considering how
cheap it was to make expect one on the
horizon
just hopefully not during another
pandemic thanks for watching everyone
make sure to like and subscribe and
leave me a comment
on what you thought about host below for
more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you